we are in the main gallery of the Albert
and Shirley small special collections
library at the University of Virginia
our current exhibition is Faulkner life
and works this is a large exhibition
surveying the Magnificent William
Faulkner collections that we have here
at the library William Faulkner was a
great American novelist who was born in
Mississippi and spent the last few years
of his career in the late 1950s and
early 1960s at UVA he's best known for
his novels the sound in the fury as a
lead eyeing sanctuary Absalom Absalom
and he was also a poet and a short story
writer well it's been quite a long time
since our last monumental Faulkner
exhibition even though we often bring
individual items out or put them on
display in other contexts we haven't
really told the full Faulkner story and
given the public access to a huge range
of materials in the collection for quite
some time it also is the 60th
anniversary of his arrival here at the
University as writer in residence and we
still have people coming to visit who
tell us about having met Faulkner while
they were here while Faulkner was at UVA
he was working on his own writing he
also spent a lot of time here in formal
and informal events meeting with
students faculty community members
faculty wives female students from local
or nearby women's colleges since UVA was
only men at the time and other groups to
talk about his novels about the state of
literature today and pretty much
anything else that they asked him about
he also really enjoyed living in
Virginia he had always had a dream to
learn to fox hunt and he learned to fox
hunt while he was here and joined the
farmington hunt and would go fox hunting
on the weekends whenever he possibly
could we have a lot of wonderful
artifacts of course from Faulkner's time
at UVA many that have come from UVA
sources among other things we have the
typewriter that he was issued by the
University even with the University
property Stan
on the back we have a jacket that he
wore he as you can see when you look at
the jacket it's it's pretty torn up and
and ratty he liked to keep his clothes
for a long time he left this jacket
hanging in his office when he went on
his last trip to Oxford Mississippi when
he passed away and in the pocket of the
jacket was a pipe and some pipe cleaners
and we even put the pipe cleaners on
display because we just thought visitors
would enjoy that close connection to
Faulkner the collections are so vast it
was really difficult to decide how to
tell the story of Faulkner's lifetime so
what we decided to do was look at the
various personae that were constructed
either by Faulkner actively or by the
circumstances in which he found himself
throughout his life and structured the
episode around those so there are 13
different aspects of his personality
displayed we tried to cover the very
personal the professional and the
lesser-known for instance I don't think
very many people know that Faulkner was
a wonderful artist and he drew all the
way through his life a lot of people
also don't know that he did really
interesting work after he won the Nobel
as a sort of literary ambassador working
for the US State Department so we tried
to pull out some unexpected stories and
also show some of the most iconic items
in the collection some materials that
demonstrate Faulkner's family history
are also on display and one that I find
incredibly interesting and poignant and
that we placed front and center at the
beginning of the exhibition is actually
from long before Faulkner was born it is
the receipt for a slave sold by
Faulkner's grandfather we thought it was
really important to put that in the
exhibition to point out just how
important that history was to how
Faulkner developed as a writer the issue
of slavery the issue of race relations
in the south these are central to his
work and are revered as topics covered
with brilliance and care throughout his
work so we really wanted to make sure
that
we put that really interesting artifact
on display as a symbol of this problem
that he inherited one of the most
interesting episodes to me of Faulkner's
life is when he spent time in Hollywood
as a screenwriter
now Faulkner would not agree with me he
didn't particularly like his time in
Hollywood it was a job that he took
writing screenplays for the studio's to
make money he was having a very hard
time making ends meet because his
writing was very difficult his books
were not selling as well as they might
have if they were more readable so he
needed to find other ways to support his
family screenwriting worked for him for
a long time he did screenwriting work
off and on for a couple of decades the
items on display are really quite
wonderful probably my favorite item is a
fragment of his screenplay for the film
The Big Sleep
which is of course considered a
masterpiece of film for its time in one
of his essays in the 1950s Faulkner
refers to himself as having the position
of a white southerner so we took that
that said what is this white southerner
figure that Faulkner inhabits anyone who
approaches Faulkner's works sees him
engaging with the problem of race and he
saw himself very much as having a
challenging position in relation
especially to the african-american
community around Oxford and members of
that community feature in fictional form
throughout his works the section of the
exhibition called white southerner looks
in particular at how Faulkner grappled
with questions of racial identity in the
South in the 1950s he wins the Nobel
Prize in 1950 and from that point on his
fame just explodes his books are sold in
massive quantities and he's known he
becomes sort of a you know a household
name and at the same time the civil
rights movement is starting to really
gather steam and the debates over
integration become more and more vocal
and more and more polarizing in the
United States so Faulkner begins to be
called upon as a public figure to
comment upon integration
he's even asked when he's abroad in
foreign countries
as an American as a southern American
tell us what you think about this issue
because of course all over the world
issues having to do with integration are
being reported we have a lot of
documents in the collection that show
Faulkner trying really hard to figure
out how to determine his own position on
integration what's wonderful about these
documents as they show that Faulkner
found himself sort of stuck between
different positions on the one hand his
view that integration needed to happen
put him at odds with a lot of whites in
Mississippi
however he often called for a slow
gradual asst move towards integration
which put him at odds with northerners
he also felt that he had a loyalty to a
south so he didn't want the north to
tell the South what to do so he's
constantly grappling and shifting his
perspective over time as an intellectual
of his moment his perspective is really
unusual and really interesting and I
found that visitors to the exhibition
really find a lot to think about in that
section and I have to say that's
probably where I learned the most in
curating the exhibition we want all
audiences to enjoy this exhibition so if
you're a Faulkner fanatic you'll be able
to commune with the manuscripts of works
and if you are not a Faulkner fanatic if
you maybe even had some trauma with
Faulkner in high school which some
people have told me they did we want you
to be able to understand his biography
because his life story is really
interesting I think we want people to
come away with a sense of Faulkner as an
entire person the whole person and all
of the aspects of his life story that
influenced his ability to sit down and
write these masterpieces so much of his
time was spent struggling to make money
struggling to care for his family it's
really remarkable to see what he
accomplished and we also want people to
get a sense of the full range of
material that can be found in a literary
archive it's a it's a real treasure and
we're so happy to be able to share it